que tal Monterrey what's up guys go
without this fella estar aqui con
ustedes it is really a thrill I can feel
your passion I can feel your curiosity I
can feel your warm reception hace que
muchísimo gracias por esta mbita's young
me face Cena
ronita Mexico seek a mil gracias the
tenor Mikey Oh gracias gracias y solo
solo por correo cidade aim levanta la
mano gente que Kanaka programa juego
mentalis brain games oh maybe
Wow okay even better okay so let's get
into this my name is Jason Silva and a
lot of people know me for hosting brain
games now brain games is a television
show that was successful I think because
it showed people how the brain perceives
reality but also how it miss perceives
reality como nuestro cerebro perceive el
mundo y tambien kimura bases no perceive
a mile we have these cognitive lapses
and these shortcomings built into our
brain and as they say we don't see the
world as it is we see the world as we
are through our cognitive lapses and our
stereotypes and all these things that
inform our perception of the world and
this plays out a lot in how we perceive
technology and innovation it is the
reason that we are often sidelined by
the pace of change it is the reason we
often fail to see the future coming and
that's what I'm going to get into today
I'm going to highlight the ways in which
the world is changing I'm going to
highlight the ways in which you are
empowered as never before to make a
positive impact on this planet and I'll
explain why our cognitive lapses often
get in
way of seeing what's right in front of
us so for this for me this all begins
with a passion for human creativity Toto
mpesa para me comunicación por la
creatividad del cerro mano como una por
una pacion por la imagenes young right
and this has turned into a passion for
technology now the reason for this is
simple technology is the embodiment of
human creativity in the world
technology is the literalization
of human imagination in the world
technology is the human mind turned
inside out and concrete eyes in the
world the cognitive philosophers David
Chalmers and Andy Clark in their seminal
essay the extended mind thesis they
actually describe technology as a
scaffolding of the mind that we use to
extend our thoughts our reach in our
vision right as the philosopher Marshall
McLuhan famously said we build the tools
and then the tools build us construe
imos la jeremy anta's luego las era
Mientus NOS construing a nosotros
relation circular we have been in a Co
evolving symbiotic relationship with our
tools and technologies since the dawn of
humanity and it has always been the case
impressed it was easy to retro series it
was as a seeing mill annuals hundred
thousand years ago in the savannahs of
Africa when early humans right were
crawling the terrain and they they
picked up a stick from the ground and
they used that stick to reach fruit that
was on a really high tree we've been
using our sticks our tools
rudimentary instruments to extend our
reach they have always been
scaffoldings and extensions of our will
they are our exoskeletons our tools are
us and we've always used our tools again
to extend our reach and to overcome our
boundaries siempre hemos Atalissa uno
tras era Mientus para sobre poner no
estrus limit a Sione's de eso se trata
that is who we are
that is who we've always been now today
we're living in the age of radical
disruption right disruption is the name
of the game change is the new status quo
acceleration itself is accelerating and
it feels like the rug is being pulled
from underneath our feet there's this
disorientation and a kind of vertigo in
the face of such rapid change and the
question is why right la tecnología
siempre a transformed ad o el mundo
siempre a transformed oddo
allow mana dad from the moment in which
we develop the wheel or when we
domesticated fire or harnessed
electricity all of these technologies
slapped us in the face and disrupted
humanity right but the difference is
between then and now is that then those
changes used to accrue over a longer
period of time so you grew up past
generations would grow up and die in a
world that didn't change that much in
their own lifespans right today it's
different today those changes are
happening in tiempo reality they're
happening at exponential speed alright
you go to college and by the time you
graduate what you studied could become
obsolete so a new way of making sense of
things is required a new kind of
thinking but first and foremost the
question remains what the hell is
happening
technology always built over time it
always changed the world over time but
it didn't matter because it happened
over many generations but now it matters
it matters to us because it's happening
in real time and we don't want to get
left behind and this has to do with the
fact that technology evolves or changes
at an exponential rate but human beings
Elsa Romano todavia piensa de forma
lineal so we are wired for linear
thinking we are wired our intuition
about change is linear but technology is
exponential you see the problem here
there is a cognitive dissonance built
into us that we are biased towards
thinking linearly right and the world is
changing exponentially as Peter
Diamandis who spoke here a number of
years ago famously said the brain
evolved in a world that was linear and
that was local and now we live in a
world that is global and that is
exponential so we need to adjust we need
to move beyond our cognitive biases and
our linear blind spots so that we can
take advantage of the unique opportunity
we live in and the exponential times
that we live in so what's the difference
between linear and exponential change
what's a real simple example that shows
the difference between linear progress
and exponential progress an example
you'll remember at the next cocktail
party you go to when you're explaining
to your friends or your parents what's
happening in the world of innovation and
tech and Ray Kurzweil who's the head of
engineering of Google who wrote a famous
book called the singularity is near when
humans transcend biology and who Bill
Gates called the best man alive at
predicting the future he uses an example
called the 30 steps example to showcase
the difference between linear and
exponential
you've probably heard this before if
you're studying tech and innovation but
just in case you haven't I want to tell
you this example again so 30 linear
steps 1 2 3 4 5 overtime gets you to 30
right that's easy
30 linear steps gets you to 30 that's
how we think about change right because
when we had to run away from lions in
the savannahs of Africa when the brain
evolved it to make a linear calculation
so that's our wiring but now take the
same 30 steps the same amount of steps
but each one is exponential so in 30
steps you actually get to a billion 30
linear steps gets you to 30 treinta
Pasolini is the yellowest treinta but 30
exponential steps gets you to a billion
treinta pathos exponent see a little
yeah Amelie Yanis same amount of steps
and technology changes exponentially so
thanks to that astounding speed that's
the reason why your smartphone that you
carry around in your pocket that you
complain when the Wi-Fi drops is
actually a million times cheaper a
million times smaller yet a thousand
times more powerful than what used to be
a 60 million dollar supercomputer that
was half the size of this building forty
years ago swallow that for a moment so
that you can appreciate the astounding
ingenuity of human beings and the
astounding progress of our technology it
used to cost 60 million dollars and was
half the size of this building and you
needed special privilege and permission
to get close to it and that
supercomputer has shrunk down to a
device a million times cheaper a million
times smaller yet a thousand times more
powerful how does this change just that
one example alone
what's possible for human beings Stephen
Johnson in his best-selling book where
good ideas come from a natural history
of innovation introduces this concept of
the adjacent possible right the
perimeters of possibility and it's a
great lens I think through which we
should be probing what we can do and
what we can achieve understanding
exponential change and then exploring
the adjacent possible that emerges when
thinking that way he describes the
adjacent possible as a shadow from the
future that hovers over the present and
provides a map of all the ways in which
the president can reinvent itself how
does the adjacent possible for Humanity
change knowing that a young kid in
Mexico with a smartphone in his hand has
better communications technology than a
president had 25 years ago for those
that complained that these technologies
are only for the rich think again a
young kid I just came back from Ellis
Island by the order where I gave a
speech to one of the largest banks and
they told me there that there's more
cell phones than people in that country
now a young kid in Mexico or in outside
of a daughter with a data plan on his
phone and a chitinous SIM card has
better communications technology than a
head of state had 25 years ago how does
this change what becomes possible
I remember reading an article by Bill
Clinton and Time magazine it was a cover
story it was called a case for optimism
and I remember in the article he cited a
United Nations study I think it was from
2010 and that study concluded that the
cellphone was the greatest invention in
human history to pull people out of
poverty think about that for a second
the age of exponential change has
brought forth tools and technologies
that are among the greatest tools and
technologies ever devised by humanity to
lift all ships to address all the grand
of humanity to help everyone potentially
right live a better life and if you
think of this analogy of the exponential
progress of the cell phone right the
price going down the size going down the
capacity going up and all of this
happening exponentially and you extend
that outwards to all information
technologies you start to understand
that we are limited only by human
imagination right so we must move beyond
the arrogance of the adult the bin bears
and seen that of the adult mind that
Michael Pollan writes about we must
instead embrace the child's eye view of
what is possible right the child that
explores but doesn't exploit right
anything's becomes possible on the back
of these exponential technologies but we
must dissolve our limited and our
limiting beliefs our patterns of
thinking those representations behind
which we are trapped think about it when
you're a child you're exploring your
world and you're creating a map of the
territory and that map provides you with
a set of familiar algorithms and
behaviors that essentially act as
shorthands to function in the world and
by the time you turn eighteen or twenty
five you're like I know the world and I
know what's possible and I know my
limits and so on and so forth and then
you give up you stop exploring the
territory and you start living inside of
your own maps your own models of reality
your own models of what's possible your
own limiting beliefs and the problem
then is the kind of amnesia that occurs
where you confuse the map for the
territory and you think those maps are
reality meanwhile reality keeps changing
technology keeps advancing exponentially
and you're still stuck in your Maps so
you must pierce through your
representations you must get through
your cognitive biases your linear way of
thinking your false belief that you've
seen it all before
and that you know what's possible
because you don't and what's possible is
actually
beyond and even greater than any example
I could give today so I think this is
cause for celebration I think human
progress is astounding I think the
capacity the uncanny ingenuity with
which we have been able to overcome
every challenge that's ever been in
front of us says something about the
human spirit I think especially when
leveraged to address the challenges
before us and impact the world in a
positive way and the inspiration that I
feel when I come across these ideas to
me at least is an antidote to the doom
and gloom and despair that you see in
the media where if it bleeds it leads
we are wired for negativity and we are
wired for fear because we are the
descendants of the most nervous humans
from the past but the truth is things
are getting better every day Steven
Pinker for example in his viral TED talk
the mists of violence showed the data of
how at the level of violence globally
the numbers added up Humanity has never
been safer and the chances of a human
dying at the hands of another human are
lower than they've ever been in all of
human history by far doesn't mean
there's not pockets of violence in the
world doesn't mean there's not problems
to be addressed but it's good to know
the numbers to see the progress to
realize that we live in the greatest
time of all and you of all of human
history by far so how to reach how to
reach people with these ideas how to get
these ideas out into the world well
we've never had a better time social
media gives each of us a voice each of
us the opportunity to get the word out
to provide an antidote to the doom and
gloom to spread positivity to spread
wonder to spread curiosity to spread aw
that is what it's all about right as
Peter Diamandis and others have said we
may be flawed stumbling primates but
when we work together my friends we are
primates that can fly that is who we are
right everything we want is on the other
side of fear the only way out is through
and so while back I started doing these
videos on the internet I call them shots
of awe busty yes des Sombra and my goal
was to I guess you could say infect
people with positivity infect people
with optimism right there's a reason
when a video spreads on the internet we
call it a viral video because the new
replicators now are not DNA molecules
they're ideas right and ideas leap from
brain to brain as James Gleick wrote
ideas have infectivity right ideas have
spreading power and even though ideas
are not made of nucleic acid they have
achieved more evolutionary change and at
a rate that leaves the old gene panting
far behind right it's like he wrote this
new kingdom that rises above the
biosphere and the denizens of this
kingdom are ideas and so I started
putting these ideas out into the world
through my videos free of charge just to
try to get people excited and I owe my
whole career to these videos and to
social media and so I'd like to show you
one of these videos here to kick things
off in an audio-visual way this video is
called to be human is to be trans human
cero mano es ser trans umano
transhumanist transcend era nuestras
limit asanas por favore el video numero
uno thank you so there's a great line by
Shakespeare in which he says we know
what we are we know not what we may be
and in the age of accelerating
technologies in which we extend the
cognitive reach of our mind
the perimeters of our humaneness with
these extensions of self these
exoskeletons these technological
scaffoldings you know the wings of our
aircrafts and the signals traveling
through our smartphone sending our
thoughts electrified at the speed of
light across oceans of sky we redefine
and extend what it means to be human
Edward o Wilson says we have actually
decommissioned natural selection and now
we must look deep within ourselves and
decide what we wish to become we are now
the chief agents of evolution we have
reversed engineered the software of
biology ER and about to rewire and
upgrade and redefined what it is to be a
homo sapien Juan Enriquez uses the term
homo evolutis the being that evolves
itself that transforms itself right
reycarts while we didn't stay in the
caves we haven't stayed on the planet
biology just
remembering to be transcended you know
Marvin Minsky used to say will robots
inherit the earth yes they will but they
will be our children you know I love
this idea because we hear the term
transhumanism and what it means to be
human is to be trans human we are the
species that transforms and transcends
we never stopped
we always did it's what we are now I'm
definitely on Team human and I have a
relentless optimism and no doubt as
you've heard me speak about exponential
technologies I see progress everywhere
now I've had the opportunity at any
opportunity viajar el mundo para
compartir Rita's esta seediest and Oh
Charla C conferences everywhere Chile at
Columbia at El Salvador at a surah
Africa Australia Dubai Abu Dhabi laundry
San Francisco you name it
la comida cuenta de poner que trata de
explicar Lisa la personas por que
pareció atonte velocidad Hinton is ok
fine a so engraved official declare pero
te creo porque lo visto so people even
though it's it's a lot to take in people
buy into the notion because obviously
they've seen it they've seen the
computer even the villa one that was
this size shrink to the iPhone they see
the iPhone double in capacity every two
years so people people understand
because they've witnessed it but what
I'm often asked pregunta is what about
you know biology we're still human
mortal beings and what about
infrastructure concrete the world of
atoms certainly those things are not
changing exponentially but no doubt you
guys came across an article a few years
ago and if you didn't you should check
it out it's called software is eating
the world and so what's happening now is
biology is becoming an information
technology and concrete atoms are
becoming an information technology too
so with biology we call it biotechnology
and with you know physic the physical
matter and atoms we call it
so let's tart with bio technology
biotechnology means mastering the
information processes of biology turns
out we are made of language if the most
a chose the linguist the most a chose
they inform us young we are made of
language and we are alphabetic all the
way down
DNA is code our genes are little
software programs and our capacity to
program and reprogram the software of
life is also accelerating at an
exponential rate in fact gene sequencing
the speed at which we can sequence our
genes is actually progressing three
times faster than exponential according
to Ray Kurzweil so it's going even
faster than those numbers I've listed
before one of the world's most eminent
physicists Freeman Dyson he wrote an
article about a new age of wonder and
biology he envisions a very near future
where a new generation of artists and
engineers will be writing genomes with
the way that the way Shakespeare and
Byron wrote versus think about that the
genome is now the new canvas the new
alphabet for human creativity and human
enterprise what are we gonna make when
we become the species that starts to
speciate itself and self evolved itself
by manipulating its own genome well
first and foremost we're gonna see a
revolution in healthcare the age of
personalized medicine is here right the
digitization and synthetic biology
will allow us to take your stem cells
and grow you a replacement Oregon if you
need it to download software patches for
biology to program your genes away from
diseases away from aging right it's
gonna change the game Bill Gates has
this dream of engineering a mosquito
that inoculates you against malaria
instead of giving you malaria and all
the kids that
from simple illnesses and don't have
access to basic medical care all of a
sudden that problem is solved the next
trillion dollar investment space forum
branded Otis is gonna be the age of
biology the age of personalized medicine
the age of a revolution in healthcare
miniature sensors in our bodies
measuring our vitals at all time
quantified self revolution feeding that
information back into the cloud finding
patterns in the data addressable
actionable things that we can do to keep
ourselves healthier the XPrize
foundation had a 10 million dollar prize
to the first team around the world that
could design a laboratory in a
smartphone they call it a medical
tricorder
and it's lab-on-a-chip technologies
right that you can deploy in a rural
village right and it can diagnose you
better than 10 doctors in a hospital
when you have a clinic in a phone how
does that change the game and you
distribute that in poor villages in
India or Mexico think about that we're
going to change not just how we address
illness it'll be finally the end of
cancer and all these other afflictions
that rob us of those we love I can't
wait until we engineer superhuman
capacities and health spans and
radically extend our lifespan and it's
going to be controversial Google
co-founder Larry Page he co-founded
calico California life extension company
a software company for biology this is
the Google guy they get it in Silicon
Valley they know the human lifespan is
gonna be radically expanded I mean we've
already done it with basic antibiotics
and vaccinations I mean people used to
die at 30 right from preventable stuff
today the lifespan pushes 80 or more but
when we can modify our genes for
longevity think about it how nice would
it be to have another hundred years of
Health to explore the universe you know
when Google co-founder with Larry Page
co-founded calico they had a cover story
in Time magazine
Google and the end of death yeah this is
not a joke because the idea of course is
like what does it mean to be human when
we don't have to die bye bye withering
away and witnessing our own decay that
existential conundrum perhaps will
finally be solved and we will engineer
our own godhood no joke
so that's biotechnology then there's
nanotechnology so the seminal book on
nanotechnology is called engines of
creation was called written by Eric
Drexler
Lomo Torres de la creación heli bro my
importantes creditos hotel and
nanotechnology and the basic analogy
that was used to explain nanotech to me
is with nanotechnology you're
programming atoms the way that you
program ones and zeros in digital
technology so look at everything that we
can do by moving ones and zeroes around
and digital tech and now imagine that
but programming atoms with nanotech that
means buildings that self assemble that
means software that can write its own
Hardware in the world that means moving
to a world beyond scarcity as Peter
Diamandis and Steven Kotler wrote in
their New York Times bestseller
abundance why the future will be better
than you think they explain it very
simply they say basically that
technology is a resource liberating
mechanism and that scarcity is
contextual so new technologies can make
things that are scarce abundant and
certainly biotechnology nanotechnology
can do that and another way of
understanding what nanotech is is look
to nature when I plant a seed from a
tree I plant the seed in the earth that
seed is an information file that seed
instructs the matter around it to grow
into a tree that's the basic idea of
nanotech software that can write its own
hardware and we'll make molecular sized
robots with nano medicine that will be
in our bodies and brains assisting us in
repairing our bodies
and nanotechnology is also advancing
exponentially just google nano medicine
it'll blow your mind so you have these
three overlapping revolutions GN are
genetics
nanotech and robotics of course
artificial intelligence is part of that
as well and in Silicon Valley the three
overlapping revolutions are leading us
towards a place that's like an event
horizon we can't see over it or like
when you go through a black hole in
physics the laws of physics get really
weird they call it a singularity the
whole enterprise of singularity
University no doubt you've heard of it
travels the world teaching business
leaders about exponential tech because
this stuff is happening and we need to
wrap our heads around it so we can
participate in creating the world beyond
our imagination in addressing the Grand
Challenges of humanity it's the most
exciting time in all of human history to
be alive and we must not forget to turn
to our artists to inspire us and paint a
picture of what becomes possible because
as Marshall McLuhan also wrote it's
always been the artist who realizes that
the future is the present and he uses
his work to prepare the grounds for it
so now I want to show you another video
is called the future of us what if I
want to be there no matter those so
let's talk about the future of us what
does that even mean the future of us
it's a look at what comes next it's a
look at what might be because today
exponentially emerging technologies are
transforming what's possible they're
helping us overcome transcend even
biological limitations the very rules of
what it is to be human are up for grabs
we're rewriting the software of life
with biotechnology we're turning matter
into a programmable medium with
nanotechnologies we're creating sentient
Minds with artificial intelligence that
are not bound by the limitations of
biology these three overlapping
revolutions en are a genetic and a
technology and robotics together will be
leveraged to lead us towards a black
hole life impossible to fathom
singularity it's like staring into the
Sun a moment of a rousing symphonic
climax when all of my references
together transcends its biological
origins and we become something more
people worry about the ai's in this -
well as Kurzweil says that's gonna be us
the future of us is ours to dream up now
as you can tell I'm very excited but
Mike yeah okay
but my excitement means nothing if you
aren't excited you are the generation
that's going to create that world of
wonders that awaits us through the
looking-glass and down the rabbit hole
there's on loss comprend odorous look
every error if I utopia beyond our
imaginations so I need you guys to feel
that inspiration I need your mental
frameworks to be upended in quaking
annihilating glory as Terence Mckenna
said I need you guys to have your world
turned inside out and upside down I need
you guys to keep exploring and not
exploiting I need you guys to probe the
perimeters of possibility you know one
of the most exciting emerging areas of
developments which I think your
creativity is vital for is the Internet
of Things
a internet de las casas so what's the
Internet of Things well as Kevin Kelly
who started Wired magazine said just the
same way that we harnessed electricity
and then we electrified the planet now
we are putting intelligent sensors you
know miniature sensors that are
advancing exponentially with AI in them
into everyday things all over the world
we're draping the planet with AI sensors
so you could think of this as like
neurons that we're putting in everything
and linking those neurons together so in
the words of Kevin Kelly we are cognate
izing the planet we're infusing the
planet with a I so connectivity in the
internet goes beyond the computer screen
and beyond the phone into everything
when everything is connected to
everything else as Eric Davis wrote
matter becomes mind because everything
has a I in it everything will have
intelligence in it everything will
gather data everything will give us
feedback
everything will revolve around us and
respond to our needs and preferences and
so the opportunity to create algorithms
and goods and services that radically
optimize our lives and creativity that
offload the things we don't want to deal
with - virtual assistants that create a
sense that the world is an extension of
our agency and we'll one of the seminal
books on the Internet of Things was
called the age of Enchanted objects
because that's essentially what's
happening similar to how indigenous
cultures in the past perceive the world
with a kind of animism everything at
agency you know the gods made it rain
and you had to talk to the trees to give
you fruit this animism we're engineering
it into the internet of things
we're literal izing our animistic dreams
of a world that is alive and can
communicate with us so the future of
entertainment the future of wellness the
future of productivity the future of
imagination and entrepreneurship on the
back of a world where all of us will be
augmented and amplified by smart
everything smart car smart thing smart
television smart lighting smart
everything it'll all be like weird the
president and we're walking around with
15 assistants optimizing our lives but
for everybody so this next video
it looks at that and I would did it with
a company called Western Digital and it
was about how big data could create a
world where the Internet of Things is
really the intelligence of things
what far we they don't have it at this
we've all heard the increasingly used
trendy term the Internet of Things
how game-changing it's going to be as we
extend sensors miniature sensors into
everyday objects everyday objects will
start to give us real-time feedback and
the world essentially will come along
this is the Internet what if we evolve
the term a little further what if
instead of the Internet of Things we
enter the realm the intelligence of
things the intelligence of things is
where the Internet of Things meets
artificial intelligence the future of
artificial intelligence is senseless
unless we extend it into the world of
everyday objects this idea that as we
impregnate intelligence into the world
of physical things that we inhabit the
world essentially will come alive this
real-time feedback this interface that
will become enlivened with intelligence
will essentially create will birth a
world that will increasingly talk back
to us now how this will change human
subjectivity how this will change the
human condition the space of mind in
which we dwell is in the following way
increasingly will dovetail our minds to
the world right and as the world starts
talking back the distinction between
self and world will start to disappear
the external space the external world
will increasingly start to feel like an
extension our mind like an extension of
our agency which will bleed over into a
world of
debility a world that will know what we
want before we want a world of
serendipity a world in which you look
for something you find something else
and he lies that what you found was more
conducive to your needs and what you
thought you were looking for we're
talking about a world optimized for
human creativity and human enterprise a
world that is responsive a world that is
alive a world that is intelligent as I
imagine so it becomes this is the very
essence of magic now you're pumping all
this data you're pumping all this AI
into sensors into the world of everyday
objects and again you birth the world
the intelligence of things the mind will
have only turns itself inside out we
will be inhabiting the condensation of
human imagination the nodes in our brain
the neurons will have spilled out into
the world we will cloak the planet in
mind and data this my friends is a
singularity of mine
meaning when everything becomes linked
with everything else matter becomes this
is the intelligence of things so as you
can see the possibilities are endless
and I have a few minutes left before my
time is up and I'd like to talk to you a
little bit about social impact because
as amazing as the possibilities are
infinite --is posibilidades de Progresso
que tenemos sino hotel estamos par
extend LAN Patea y para impact r+ Amenti
a los demás
lo que Matt Lohr Alok a matter or
necesitan and ptosis it's for nothing so
we need to use these tools and
technologies to address the Grand
Challenges of humanity and to help those
that need it most so a while back the
folks at singularity University and
other institutions that think about
exponential change propose this notion
in the age of Exponential's everybody
wants to be the next Mark Zuckerberg
everybody's trying to figure out how
they can become a billionaire you know
come up with a quick idea program it
with an algorithm boom go viral and
you're rich but what if we what if we
redefine the term billionaire in the age
of exponential technologies what if we
reframe what it means to be a
billionaire right what if in the age of
exponential technologies a billionaire
is somebody who positively touches a
billion lives because that's what's
possible that's what you guys can do and
what a beautiful yes exactly
what a beautiful what a beautiful matrix
what a beautiful way of measuring
success you know today the epidemic of
anxiety and of depression has reached
global scale more people are committing
suicide than are dying from natural
disasters and armed conflict combined so
people are hungry for meaning and
purpose and signification and the
pathologies of mental distress I think
are
proof that people need something to
believe in to believe that life is
inherently meaning full not meaning less
that progress is real and possible and
again we may be flawed stumbling
primates but that when we work together
we are primates that can fly we are the
captains of spaceship earth and we are
all right
the captain's the crew we must work
together and also like to mention the
importance I think of remaining open the
power of awe and wonder el poder
cognitive Oh yellow beneficial cognitive
oohs de la sombra Aoyama my videos back
tienes hambre shots of awe a letter a
song ok there's research coming out now
and universities like Berkeley and
Stanford they have studied how blowing
our minds essentially how experiences
that smash the models of reality that we
have built up are cognitively beneficial
so they describe a la sombra as an
experience of such perceptual expansion
when experiencia suficiente expansion
mentally that these mental models of the
world are dissolved to make room for the
new experience maybe the first time you
saw your child being born or when you
fell in love for the first time or when
you learned how an iPhone works you know
and these experiences of awe they leave
an afterglow of increased well-being
increase creativity and and and have
cognitive anti-inflammatory effects as
well and of course an increase in
empathy so what you have then is a
realization that exposure to ideas that
are outside your comfort zone exposure
to ideas that are beyond your
representation exposure to ideas that
challenge you to think outside the box
to fall down the rabbit hole to step
through the looking-glass are actually
cognitively beneficial it's good for
your creativity it's good for your
curiosity it's good for you to follow
your bliss and so that's the inspiration
for my videos and so I want to leave you
with one more video it's called the
captains of spaceship earth and the
video again is about our capacity to
positively touch a billion lives to blow
our own minds with inspiration and to
believe in the words of Barack Obama yes
we can so please show it próxima be
there but for what we live in a world of
exponential technological advancements
what this literally means that we have
new construction kits for our reality
new tools with which to probe at the
adjacent possible to consider the
implications right as Marshall McLuhan
used to say first we build the tools and
then the tools build us we are designed
by what we have designed there are these
feedback loops of mind tool and world
that radically redefined our boundaries
that radically transform what it means
to be human to be human today is to
crisscross the skies to be human today
is to create techno social wormholes so
what do we do well we need to radically
reach out to one another in ways that we
haven't before there's a great line that
says empathy rarely extends beyond our
line of sight in other words it's out of
sight it is
but if anything is wireless
communication technologies are astronaut
overview effect we are seeing the big
picture and what shall we do we need to
extend our hands to one another we've
never had such tools to overcome all of
the limitations of our humanity have the
power and will we have the capacity the
creative capacity to overcome what is
new definition of billionaire the new
definition of billionaire is he who will
positive
the lives of a billion
he or she will reach out and say I will
positively affect the lives of a billion
people this should be our goal this is
our responsibility
here's our cheese so there you go guys
that would be thank you you guys are
awesome thank you that's yes lastly I
could ask you ask yes
potassium mucho gracias gracias
so that is the end of my talk I hope I
hear from all of you please connect with
me on the social webs
I'm Jason el Silva on instagram jason
silva on twitter i hope to continue the
conversation look at a mucho gracias
that's yes that's recipe Jason
[Applause]